cas françois durpaire historien
spécialiste des états unis bonsoir
françois roy accord doit s'attendre ce
soir un débat houleux selon vous oui
parce qu'en fait tout le monde peut
encore gagner alors faut se dire que
c'est pas un débat général c'est pas un
débat national c'est un débat où on a
les yeux tournés vers le nevada vers
leur prochaine les dictionnaires
donc on va vraiment et il n'est pas là
c'est assez ouvert parce qu'on n'a pas
énormément de sondages
traditionnellement c'est un état on a
petit nuage et où effectivement c'est
assez ouvert c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
encore de belles temps annoncé on a
effectivement un candidat qui est favori
parce que il est il ya maintenant une
avance à deux chiffres il a 31 %
c'est sanders mais en même temps il est
socialiste
est-ce que ça va aller jusqu'au bout
c'est quand même assez étonnant puis
alors évidemment l'inconnue de la nuit
c'est l'arrivée de bloomberg dans la
course c'est la première fois qu'on va
le voir le milliardaire l'homme qui
valait 50 7 milliards de dollars c'est
c'est ça qui va être intéressant parce
que dépenser d'argent est une chose
faire des pubs pré enregistré et balancé
à la télé à la radio 300 millions $
quand même dépensé c'est une chose mais
être en débat c'en est une autre
donc là on va voir comment bloomberg va
se comporter face aux autres sachant que
lui sera pas dans des vallées il attend
le super tuesday
il a fait l'impasse à les imaginer comme
le sport il commence pas la course il
attend il attend les finales les demi
finales et la finale
alors c'est par nos vies quand même et
qu'elle en looberghe
vite voilà le débat c'est toute chose
mais c'est un homme rompu il ya de
l'expérience
est-ce qu'il peut créer selon vous la
surprise oui alors pour effectivement
d'abord ce que vous avez dit il a de
l'expérience faut quand même voir qu'il
a dirigé pendant douze ans une ville new
york qui et c'est l'économie de la corée
du sud
c'est de quasiment je crois en ses 70
milliards de budget donc c'est plus que
40 états américains donc c'est vraiment
même si généralement on ne devient pas
président après avoir été maire on va
avoir été plutôt gouverneur ou sénateurs
donc une expérience c'est son premier
atout deuxième atout c'est que c'est une
sorte de train va prendre 30 à son
propre jeu
d'abord est ce qui est beaucoup plus
riche que lui qui peut dépenser encore
plus d'argent et écrivez excusez-moi de
cette phrase il est il et il est ok sur
la politique salle sert que jusqu'à
maintenant trump on ne prend toujours
par le haut vous souvenez la phrase de
michèle obama qui conseillait à tous les
démocrates
ils vont essayer watts et golo we go way
quand ils font quelque chose de bas
quand il fonctionne alors oui pas du
tout lui il va prendre trump avec les
gants de boxe vous souvenez de cette
image il a déjà dit moi j'ai pas peur
avec ces faux cheveux et son et son et
soi et son bronzage vaporiser il me fait
pas peur donc on va avoir à quelque
chose d'assez d'assez physique il est
capable de le prendre à son propre jeu
et puis et puis la dernière peut-être le
dernier atout c'est que c'est son
positionnement
vous savez quand il ya une économie
aussi florissante on est au milieu de la
phase d'expansion la plus importante de
l'histoire des états unis
c'est difficile d'arriver en disant on
va changer tout on va transformer le
changement c'est maintenant non alors
lui c'est intéressant parce qu'il va pas
d'idée du va pas dire le changement
c'est maintenant il va dire on continue
tout l'économie je suis un homme
d'affaires
l'homme de wall street etc en revanche
vous propose un changement sur le style
or quand on regarde des américains les
sondages c'est oui on aime le job de
on n'aime pas trop son style donc là ils
ont peut-être à donald trump sans le
style donald trump
là vous m'avez fait parler des atouts un
geste homicide et nous ne vous inquiétez
pas réunir alors sont justement une
chance qu'on peut lire prochaines heures
bernie sanders a déjà commencé
injustement l'attaqué sur l'argent c'est
ça s'empire son pirate ou wifi sans
qu'un défaut j'avais voulu d'un
stéphanie sait il n'est pas démocrate
c'est là qu'on fait la majorité des
démocrates eux considèrent comme un
républicain et un démocrate modéré qui
pourrait faire le pendant de sanders qui
serait le démocrate gauchiste mais ils
se disent mais qu'est ce qu'il a
vraiment de démocrates
alors évidemment le gros problème c'est
que 30
il a gagné des états qui sont des états
démocratiques à gauche il a gagné luis
win thin la pennsylvanie et lé michigan
pour un démocrate faudrait reconquérir
louvrier or quel est le démocrate moins
bien placé pour reconquérir l'ouvrier
l'homme de wall street
deuxième chose il case il coche
aucune des autres cases les jeunes non
les minorités non plus les femmes non
plus pour des raisons x ou y ont à
parvenir son sexisme ses propos etc
et puis il ya aussi une casserole c'est
que tranquille il fait très bien sur le
patriotisme économique c'est ce à quoi
fonctionner chez lui or vous savez que
le bloomberg lp son entreprise fait tous
les ans une conférence sur la chine où
la chine est formidable et c'est quand
vous demandez aux américains aujourd'hui
la menace et qui sait la chine et et lui
sa dernière conférence il a fait à pékin
pour dire tout le bien qu'ils pensaient
l'économie chinoise et pour dire
également le parti communiste écoute la
population chinoise et s'adonne altran
va lui sortir en débat ainsi c'est donc
il a quand même un certain nombre de
handicaps qui font que
c'est pas gagné quand même alors senders
bloomberg les autres soyez vous les avez
relégué déjà gelé relecq pas parce que
le peuple américain ne les a pas
reléguer on est encore dans une campagne
démocrate d'abord sanders et 13 en tête
ne peut pas maîtriser démocrate il ya
une proportionnelle ça veut dire que on
a le fameux 1991 c'est pas une date
c'est le nombre de délégués pour
l'emporter
il va avoir du mal à les avoir parce que
c'est toujours à la proportionnelle et
même un gars comme by john qui a été en
tête des sondages nationaux pendant très
longtemps
6dans m'évade à bientôt y leon et gagne
alors mumbai donne pour l'instant ça va
pas du tout hein mais vous me demandez
ce que je les cartes on est là on a un
grand favori sanders messenger c'est
quand même un problème j'ai les
démocrates hier que sanders candidat
c'est un programme assez un problème
parce que le américain moyen il voit
quoi ans anders ou 10 le socialisme ans
et pas l'idéologie qui pose un problème
il se dit par contre baisses d'impôts et
par où est ce que ça va pas remonter
c'est quand même sanders eu quand même
ça pose problème à l'américain moyen
et si sanders n'est pas candidat c'est
peut-être encore plus un problème parce
que vous fait quoi des boîtes saunders
pour l'instant l'électorat démocrate
yves bot sanders vous rappeler que
sanders il a fait encore partie la
défaite d'hillary clinton
parce que il n'a pas reporté ses voix
sur hillary clinton enfin les américains
n'ont pas voté ceux qui avaient voté
s'inverse n'ont pas voté majoritairement
clinton et s'il est en tête ce sera
encore pire
l'establishment pourra pas expliqué
qu'il faudra mettre bloomberg nous
faudra mettre quelqu'un d'autre donc on
peut avoir à la convention des supers
délégués qui seraient du côté
effectivement de quelqu'un un peu
modérer centriste mais avec un fond
d'électorat démocrate qui serait très à
gauche et ça ça serait et là évidemment
comment vous dire ça serait du petit
lait c'est le rêve éveillé pour donald
trump voiture est un débat important ce
soir pour cette course à l'investiture
démocrate
ouais il faut manquer aucun épisode de
la série
donald trump et la réélection en
novembre prochain
ça va être évidemment intéressant un
débat intéressant et qui va nous amener
vers le nevada est évidemment manquera
pas le 3 mars prochain en cours avec le
décalage on va se lever tous et merci
beaucoup apprécié françois